a lot to talk about here you're having
such great success but I want to ask you
about something everyone gets into this
business in a different way and you sort
of came in through the the you did a lot
of voiceover work is that right that's
correct yeah you have a good voice I
have an amazing voice I did yeah that's
I did a lot of voiceovers I have a few
running at the moment there's one in
particular Sharp Aquos liquid crystal
televisions sharp say it again office
liquid crystal television
I'll do I'll do the official I want to
hear it yeah line for you Sharp Aquos
liquid crystal televisions suddenly
there's more to see you really do feel
when you say that that there is more to
see yeah that's great now do you okay
when you look for this commercial do you
get excited when the commercial comes on
and you can hear yourself it was it's
always it's always funny and sometimes
it pops on it's surprising times that
like last year my dad and I were
Christmas shopping and we're looking for
a flat-screen TV for him and we were at
a Circuit City and you know how like
there's a whole Bank of TVs right at a
Circuit City and so all of a sudden this
commercial comes on Sharp Aquos okay and
my dad freaks out he's like everybody
shut up that's my boy and everyone's
looking at the TVs and I'm not in the
commercial there's just like a woman
[Music]
boys a woman it's great
so what TV did your dad into buying a
Panasonic pencil which was a grave
mistake because he should have bought a
Sharp Aquos liquid-crystal television
suddenly there's more to see we were
always interested in show business when
you were as a child did you know I want
to be a performer you know I was not
like that class clown type of guy
growing up but I did I think there was
always that urge as I said the SNL fan
when I was a little kid sure and I one
of my early showbiz experiences was
ironically horrendous which was when my
dad took me to a foul Atlanta Hawks game
and the halftime show was was a guy in a
unitard who twirled a baton and he was
amazing like he really blew my mind and
I went home that night it was like
that's what I'm gonna do you went to a
football game and came away saying I'm
gonna be the baton exactly it was
exactly what my dad wanted from me but
but my sister had a baton and so I
started practicing and I got pretty good
and I got dangerously cocky yeah
and so my brother had a birthday party
coming up and he goes he's like I'm
trying to figure out what I'm gonna do
for the birthday party I'm like hello
I've got some entertainment for you how
about a baton twirling show yeah and so
I performed it and I of course it was
choreographed to eye of the tiger really
no other song that I share yeah and I
and I did it for all these 10 year olds
gathered in the in the living room and I
was really selling it and I had all the
moves down I was great right and rocking
it and I hit the final pose and I was
attacked by my brother and his friends
and they beat me with the baton
that's the greatest humiliation as
you've beaten with your own baton no
it's true with the center of my dream by
my own family it's not good I watched
the show last night I watched you on the
office and it's a hilarious show you're
very funny on this program it's a very
funny episode in the episode you play
the banjo yeah you're very good I I do
play the banjo I've been playing the
banjo for quite a while minute I have a
bluegrass trio the lonesome trio that we
I actually play guitar in that group but
yeah big big music guy
what a year and so you're you love music
what were your musical influences would
you say I love all music dangerous music
everywhere like every movie I've ever
seen hmm no I
Beethoven - Bill Monroe - what what have
you I have a couple of guilty pleasures
among them Yanni
I think Yanni is a genius give me an e
on e the New Age musician yes Yanni the
the long black hair huge mustachioed
musician I I feel like he's
underappreciated and I always loved his
his work and I often listed it connects
to my soul and I often find myself it's
all its instrumental music yeah but but
I find the music you hear when you're
getting a massage yes okay that sounds
bad
uh-huh but but I like to think of what
like when I listen to it it makes me sad
there's no words because it conjures so
much imagery for me so I was I always
kind of sing along with yawning me get
this straight you list when you hear
Yanni you you come up with words for
Yanni's songs and you sing along with it
yes really yes I do
if we played you a little Yanni right
now would you let and just on the spur a
moment we have some Yanni here what
we're just gonna play some Yanni and
just I think there's a microphone around
here somewhere and we always eat one
right there yeah it's funny you knew
just how to find it let's let's just
give it a shot
you feel that do you feel it yeah it's
that's terrible
see the little unicorn there he is
eating
he is eating his unicorn food see the
little unicorn
he is prancing he's transferred his
unicorn prize I see that you are amazing
and I see you sidle up to your mother
and suckle girl unicorn team I believe
if I removes your horn and grounded into
a powder and mix it with vodka it would
be the most incredible aphrodisiac
do you feel the baddest name
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]